- His name is Ever, is that
short for something or what?
- No, Ever is a name
that I just always loved
and it's funny, 'cause
you were talking about
your Italian family and you
and I have talked a lot about
coming from these very big
and vibrant Italian families.
So it's always part of
the family tradition
that we tell what the name is
and that everyone can be
involved in the decision
and of course, they wanted to use
all of the existing family names,
like my cousin is Gina Nicole
and her sister's Nicole Gina
and then there's Thomas Anthony,
Anthony Thomas and they were like,
aren't you gonna name the baby, Anthony?
I'm like, we have 10 Anthonys.
(audience laughs)
I think it's good, but
they love the name, Ever,
when they found out what it was,
except it's actually sounding
a little bit more like Eva,
it's for my--
Eva, you know, Eva!
With the accents.
- Yeah, now where does
it come from though?
- [Female Speaker] The name?
- Yeah, how did you
come up with that name?
- I don't remember I think I'm probably
found it on a baby name
blog or something like that.
- Well, see I'd never heard
that as a name until your child.
- Okay, actually we'll say that
Alanis Morissette son's name was, Ever,
and I loved it so much when
I heard that she had it,
so I sort of stole it.
- Oh, ah-hah, ah-hah!
- Oh no, I can believe I just said that!
(Female speaker chuckles)
- All right, now we see how
we get to the truth here.
- I don't even think
my husband knows that.
- [Male Speaker] Really?
- No!
- [Male Speaker] Wow!
- I was just like,
I came up with it on my
own, I had a dream about it.
That's what I should've said,
it came to me in a dream.
- Okay, okay, well it's too late now.
- I know.